Sam Smith is being all gay and also the
devil son the Christian
basic industry to sell albums for years
they're the outrage engine of the music
industry it's like heavy metal it's Sam
Smith also my man is gay he's being what
you think he's sure everyone's always
like gay people are going to hell and
he's like all right I'm in hell sign me
up stop it don't do it that way let me
see this he's paying homage to the guy
that you say that he loves yeah it's
like this is your idea he wouldn't even
know what the [__] hell is unless you
said gay people was going there yeah so
he's just biting little nazex
also did it Christians got all upset but
I mean that's the same [__] little nazex
gay mad devil [__] another video
musicians have been playing on
Christians fearing the devil they're
just the first two gay people to do it
yeah but all I'm trying to say is like
yo if you're a Christian you can't be
mad if a gay dude is embracing hell
that's your fault that is your fault
that's true say he's welcome in heaven
now you can have a problem with it yeah
who's this
that's Sam Smith bro oh no she's trans
wait who is that Bebe rexha that's Kim
Petras I'm pretty sure who's Kim no she
is trans Petra's trance yeah yeah but
it's all that [__] yeah
right a day something like that
this [__] guy bro okay you said a
word about his outfit so I did I told
you about his ankles you trying to hate
right now
I like this one
he dressed like Bill Murray in that boat
movie
what's up
guys that's really good life Aquatics
that's good bro
do you think he looks like a long he's
not get into the pictures because
technology
so I can get this or not he had this
[__] up for an hour
hey I had it up for two hours it's crazy
bro oh yeah wait a minute no no you
don't think he looked like no Mark just
too regular I already thought about it
I'm getting bullied into neutrality
that's the thing I just know it's normal
and then no one says anything you look
like Captain America before
[Laughter]
yeah I like that because the shirt's all
big
hey guys if you explain it you know it's
hilarious Google Life Aquatic though
that was fire yeah no I like aquatic I
got two of them that was fire oh I got
blew that I don't know if you gotta
Google it's really funny
yeah
it's good oh boy that's a great
reference okay
um but look it all yes it is him it's
good okay [__] good in all
seriousness can you give me another
topic Mark yes because I don't know if
we spoke about these Chinese balloons
you definitely did what let me talk
about them in a second
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no she is from North Korea she's a
Defector from North Korea how you know
you did mad bad on that test
[Laughter]
that is an Indian guy
yeah he's a mud drill in India thank you
thank you you know what I mean
compromise you know you find it okay but
seriously can we get back to this app
yes son of a [__] Francis and gun is
accepted a fight with Tyson Fury oh
that's not what it was fun
[Music]
I was just bringing up a story oh he's
accepted I wasn't sad when I said I
wasn't being sick
he accepted the fight friends and gone
who anti-zer Furious scheduled actually
I don't know the schedule but they have
accepted the fight
it's a big fight
and I'm not happy about it why aren't
you happy about it cause I'm pissed off
why why are you pissed off what's
bothering you what's got your panties in
a bunch it's just what's got your butt
lips tuckered after a long day on a
range
what that's not what I'm saying what has
got your mouth chapped yo what's up with
you bro what what are you doing to your
cat why is your cat always scratching
you oh no this is just one time I was
playing yeah
[__]
also you don't think I can [__] my cat
without gonna scratch it's a small cat
it's literally a tiny cat I don't think
you could you could absolutely not I
don't think you could yes you could kill
it first obviously but then it's no fun
yeah you wouldn't have to kill you could
just push it down
it's not hard you can [__] a cat dude I
think you should no he's mad confident
he could [__] his cats easily you
[__] your cat no because I got
scratched that means I was playing nah
he was like oh we're talking about a cat
here a cat has the ability to
shape-shift
[__] cat no no without getting
scratched is the big thing you put in
there yeah it's not it goes wild and
[__] I would imagine I'm a cat [__]
like you are you I never [__] a cat
nah but I don't think it would be that
hard are you like forcing your cat into
being affectionate you're like holding
it too long and then just scratches to
get away I will do that which is almost
more sad than [__] peanut butter on
your nuts and you have it looks like
peanut butter oh they don't it's
throwing that out yeah
so there I am that's why you got
scratched yeah I ruined our peanut
butter for no reason yeah it's [__]
it's frustrating yeah ruin the peanut
butter because I put my whole dick in
the peanut butter dude just to find out
cats don't even like peanut butter in
the first place that's annoying out of
the peanut butter jar oh man I did an
American Pie still eating the peanut
butter after a Dick's been inside
I'm not gonna let it goes that is crazy
yeah you're gonna throw away perfectly
peanut butter it's my dick
wait a minute wait you put your dick in
here and your peanut butter wait a
minute who's on first guys son oh that's
why he won't let Mouse live over there
yeah
after hanging out with Miles the other
night I completely understand why like
no way no one's [__] my cap of me
miles no not even I'm talking about the
party like that's my point dude you guys
a couple too many and then oh he's
unpredictable